Mit unserem Universum stimmt etwas nicht und zwar
so richtig. Dass es auseinanderfliegt steht seit
1927 fest und das es dabei immer schneller wird
seit 1998 auch. Doch etwas ist dabei konstant.
Naja fast oder nicht oder so genau waeiß man das
nicht. Die Astronomie tappt wahrhaftig im Dunklen,
denn je nachdem wie man die die Hubblekonstante,
die die Expansion definiert, mißt kommt etwas
gänzlich anderes dabei raus. Clixoom Science
& Future - hier gibt es drei Mal pro Woche
spannende Science-Video. Abonniert den Kanal und
aktiviert die Glocke; nur so verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich Willkommen. Dieses Video ist entstanden
in Kooperation mit Readly.de. Dem digitalen
Abokiosk für’s Smartphone oder Tablet. Für nur
regulär 9,99 Euro gibt es nahezu alle Magazine
und Zeitschriften. Der Link ist hier unterm i mit
einem besonders günstigen Sonderangebot für euch:
Der erste Monat ist gratis und ab dann monatlich
9,99 Euro und es kann jederzeit gekündigt werden.
Und wir haben dieses megaspannende Thema
dort auf Readly.de in Spektrum Sterne und
Weltraum gefunden. Aber es gibt noch mehr als 5000
weitere Magazine dazu auf Readly. Readly ist wie
das Netflix für Magazine. Wissenschaftlich
gesehen ist es eine Katastrophe. Denn umso
genauer man den Wert der Hubblekonstante
bestimmen will, desto ungenauer werden die
Ergebnisse oder unterschiedlicher. Das ist
wirklich paradox,. denn die Messergebnisse
werden eigentlich immer genauer, aber liegen
immer deutlicher auseinander. Aber wie kann
das sein? Wie ist das Unmögliche möglich? Und
diese tatsächlich ziemlich aussichtslose Lage
der Kosmologie. Die Forschenden versuchen bei
jedem Verfahren ein möglichst exaktes Ergebnis
zu erzielen, aber je nach Verfahren sind die
Ergebnisse vollkommen anders. Zur Messung der
Expansion des Universums werden Himmelskörper
herangenommen, von denen man ganz exakt weiß,
wie hell und wie heiß sie sind. Wie bei einem
Leuchtturm weiß die Forschung so viel über diese
Himmelskörper, dass sehr viele weitere Werte
an ihnen bestimmt werden können, unter anderem
eben die Hubblekonstante. Denn sie beschreibt die
Geschwindigkeit, mit der das Universum auseinander
fliegt. Und das tut das Universum mit zunehmender
Entfernung mit immer höherer Geschwindigkeit. Die
Hubblekonstante beschreibt deshalb auch keine
fest Geschwindigkeit, sondern die Zunahme der
Geschwindigkeit mit steigender Entfernung. Sie
wird pro Megaparsec ermittelt, das entspricht
einer Entfernung von 3.260.000 Lichtjahren. Und
dieser Wert liegt bei….Ja, das kann ich einfach
nicht sagen. Je nachdem, was man misst, kommt ein
anderes Ergebnis raus. Namensgeber Edwin Hubbel
lag bei seinen eigenen Messungen noch komplett
daneben. Er hatte Sterne verwechselt und kam so
auf ein Ergebnis von 500 Kilometern pro Sekunde
und Megaparsec. Also pro Megaparsec nahm die
Geschwindigkeit kaut Hubble pro Megaparsec zu.
Eine Galaxie also, die ein Megaparsec von uns
entfernt ist, würde sich nach hubble Berechnungen
mit 500 Kilometern pro Sekunde entfernen,
eine Galaxie im Abstand von 2 Megaparsec doppelt
so schnell, also mit 1000 Kilometern pro Sekunde
undsoweiterundsofort. Das Prinzip scheint
tatsächlich zu gelten und wurde immer wieder
bestätigt, nur der Wert lag bei den Ergebnissen
von Hubble komplett daneben. Sein Fehler war, dass
er andere Sterne mit den Cepheiden verwechselte.
Diese Sterne verändern periodisch ihre Leuchtkraft
und Größe und mit Hilfe der Dauer der Periode
kann ihre Leuchtkraft definiert werden. Das heißt,
dass man ihre Helligkeit sehr genau kennt
und damit ihre Entfernung exakt bestimmen
kann. Verwechselt man diese Sterne nun, wie
es Hubble unterlaufen ist, dann kommt man zu
falschen Ergebnissen. Da die Leuchtkraft mit der
Entfernung abnimmt, weiß man damit sehr genau,
wie weit sie entfernt sind. Die Geschwindigkeit
kann jetzt durch die Rotverschiebung des Lichts
ermittelt werden. Die setzt sich zusammen aus
der Eigengeschwindigkeit von Objekten und eben
der Expansion des Universums. Für beide gilt,
wenn sich Objekte von uns entfernen, dann wird
die Frequenz niedriger, beim Licht röter. Bei
Schall tiefer. Das kennen wir als Dopplereffekt
von vorbeifahrenden Autos mit Martinshorn. Kommen
sie auf uns zu, ist der Ton hoch und entfernen sie
sich, wird der Ton tiefer. Jetzt muss man die
Eigengeschwindigkeit der Sterne herausrechnen
und schon hat man die Geschwindigkeit, mit
der sich die Sterne entfernen. Weiter Sterne,
bei denen man die Leuchtkraft genau kennt, sind
Supernovae vom Typ 1a oder Rote Riesensterne,
wie zum Beispiel Beteigeuze, die an einem exakt
definierten Punkt ihrer Entwicklung explodieren.
Es gibt also drei verschiedenen Arten von Sternen,
bei denen die Astronomie so viel über sie weiß,
dass sie Entfernung und Geschwindigkeit exakt
bestimmen kann. Aber auch mit der kosmischen
Hintergundstrahlung oder Gravitationslinsen
lässt sich die Hubblekonstante bestimmen.
Von all diesen kosmischen Phänomenen gibt es so
viele Informationen, dass die Hubblekonstante
exakt bestimmt werden kann. Und jetzt wird es
frustrierend: Diese exakten Ergebnisse sind
grundverschieden. Erst Anfang der 10er Jahre
wurden die Daten des Planck-Weltraumteleskops
veröffentlicht. Es lieferte die bislang
detailreichste Karte der Kosmischen
Hintergrundstrahlung und eine Hubblekonstante von
67,74 km pro Sekunde je Megaparsec. Das Spitzer
Weltraumteleskop lieferte dagegen anhand Cepheiden
davor einen Wert von 74,3, Hubble mit Cepheiden
und Supernovae vom Typ 1a 74,2. Die beiden Werte
liegen ja wenigsten einigermaßen beieinander und
wenn man berücksichtigt, dass beide Messungen
eine Abweichung von plusminus 2,1 kilometer pro
Sekunde und Megaparsec bei Spitzer und 3,6 beim
Hubble Weltraumteleskop zulassen, dann decken
sich die Ergebnisse fast. Zunichte machen das
aber wieder die Messungen an Gravitationslinsen,
also so starken Gravitationsfeldern zum Beispiel
um Galaxien, die das Licht von Objekten wie eine
Linse so stark krümmen, dass Galaxien dahinter
zwei oder sogar viermal auftauchen. Dabei legt
das Licht unterschiedliche Wege zurück. Zum
einen sind es tatsächlich Umwege durch die
Krümmung der Raumzeit in der Gravitationslinse
und zum anderen unterliegt ein Lichtstrahl, der
durch den dichteren Teil der Gravitationslinse zu
uns gelangt, größeren relativistischen Effekten,
d. h. einer größeren Zeitdilatation, die Zeit
im Lichtstrahl läuft langsamer. Das sind Effekte
von einigen Wochen und Monaten. Das Ergebnis
69,7 Km pro Sekunde und Megaparsec. Es ist
wirklich zum Mäusemelken. Und es geht hier nicht
um irgendeine Petitesse, eine Unwichtigkeit. Diese
unterschiedlichen Ergebnisse stellen die gesamte
Kosmologie in Frage. Stimmt das etwa alles nicht,
was wir über unseren Kosmos wissen? Welche
der drei Grundannahmen ist also falsch? Gilt
die Relativitätstheorie nicht? Das ist mit
an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit
auszuschließen. Sie wurde in so unendlich vielen
praktischen Versuchen immer wieder bestätigt. Das
ist nahezu unmöglich? Gibt es etwa keine Dunkle
Materie? Oder stimmt etwas nicht mit der Dunklen
Energie? Für die Dunkle Energie gibt es ja eine
heiße Spur. Wir haben hier ja gerade erst mit
Professor Günther Hasinger gesprochen,
dem wissenschaftlichen Direktor der ESA,
der Schwarze Löcher für die Dunkle Materie hält.
Und die Dunkle Energie? Da gibt es ja die größten
Fragezeichen. Könnte es hier durch die Vereinigung
von Quantenphysik und Relativitätstheorie eine
neue sichtweise ergeben? Ist sie vielleicht
ein Feld, dass in mehr als in unseren bekannten
vier Dimensionen existiert? ... und dadurch
veränderlich ist? Denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen:
Umso weiter weg die gemessenen Objekte
zur Bestimmung der Hubblekonstante sind,
desto älter sind sie und damals könnte eben
ein anderer Wert für die Dunkle Energie
gegolten haben. Und das würd bedeuten, dass
wir in einem ganz anderen Universum leben,
als wir bisher gedacht haben. Das Thema stammt aus
Readly.de. Eine App, die ich schon seit geraumer
Zeit nutze, weil man da wirklich nahezu alles
findet. Wie zum Beispiel hier Die Hubblekrise in
Spektrum Sterne und Weltraum. Allein für dieses
Magazin lohnt sich schon das Readlyabo. Und es
ist papierfrei. Kein einziger Baum wird gerodet.
Aber auf Readly gibt es noch weitere mehr als 5000
Magazine. Das Sonderangebot für euch gibt es hier.
Einfach draufklicken! Der Link ist übrigens auch
in der Videobeschreibung. Also draufklicken
und los geht’s! Bis dann, bleibt dran!